well it couldn't get more Vegas than
this a couple finds a cat inside their
hotel room on the Strip at four in the
morning they document the whole thing on
Tick Tock and so far it's got 1.2
million viewers but as Victoria Saha
explains this cat had been there for
days before it was discovered
so what's up
what Lindsay
Lindsay's and her husband woke up to on
day three of their stay at the Excalibur
no cats in my hotel room we're used to
being woken up by our cats at our house
you know that's like run-of-the-mill for
us but not expected while you're like on
vacation Sanders and her husband are
both veterinarians and we're in town for
a conference when they made the
discovery they quickly called security
and their reaction only in Vegas
we didn't know if he was like a feral
who would somehow snuck into our room
the cat was spooked by security and
crawled into the sink cabinet a spot he
was likely hiding in all along buddy
he's okay the Sanders quickly realized
that tiger wasn't just a stray cat he
was in fact a guest that overstayed his
welcome at the Excalibur meanwhile his
owner was anxious to find him like my
soul was kind of cracking just six days
before the Sanders checked in Shanice
Williams and her 16 year old cat tiger
were staying in the same room while
moving to Las Vegas from Reno but I was
calling him he didn't come out and I was
just looking for him and I couldn't find
him and then I just kind of went into
panic mode Williams tells us she thought
tiger had run out of the room I had no
other choice but to kind of keep going I
mean I did what I could as far as
leaving the information and providing a
picture of tiger and when she got the
call Six Days Later the tiger was found
she was ecstatic I was just glad had to
not think of him as like starving
somewhere so how did the Sanders not
realize they were sharing their room
with an unexpected guest there was like
pee on the side of the shower I blame my
husband and he was very adamant that he
did not do that it's safe to say that
that was most likely Tiger's fault
Victoria Saha eight news now tiger is 16
years of age by the way all right he was
there for six days without food or water
well the Vets say he did look a bit
dehydrated most likely drink water from
the toilet something his owner says he
does quite often